[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission au sein de sa
découverte alors allons-nous
[Musique]
dans la commune de Saint-Luc pas trop
loin du viaduc de la Fontaine alors
point de repère ça de monnaie là ça nous
a fait c'est que Missa empreinte une
partie du chemin pavé et nous va
atterrir à la ville de Saint-Leu allez
Vanessa commence par là allons-nous
alors du coup le sentier pour jeunesse
comment ça va ça va bien dis-moi je suis
en train de chercher le chemin pavé qui
amène jusqu'à centre ville de Saint-Luc
et ben c'est juste ce petit sentier là
toujours tout droit d'accord
et vous vous venez d'où comme ça vous
euh de la ravine cancer et je monte
là-haut excellent donc d'accord donc du
coup vous avez emprunté le chemin pavé
voilà et comment ça se fait que vous
connaissez ce sentier là vous
parce que j'aime bien trotter un petit
peu de partout et maintenant j'habite un
peu dans les Hauts à la fontaine et du
coup je vais au travail à pied je
remonte à pied à tous les jours
ça fait combien de kilomètres en combien
de temps on fait ça alors du coup en
kilomètres je sais pas mais en 30 35
pour descendre ouais à peu près pareil
pour monter si on a un bon rythme et en
terme de repère si on veut se repérer
pour démarrer le sentier ici là est-ce
que il y a un repère
ici là
ici là il y a la route tamarin qui a 50
mètres là d'accord voilà OK et il y a de
même de quoi se garer donc si on veut le
commencer directement ici bah vous
prenez la piste et au premier virage
vous partez là il y a le le petit signal
en vert d'accord effectivement ils sont
un peu comment c'est du bas à côté de là
où ils font les concerts ou sur un peu
commencé juste là alors vous avez dit
exactement bon en tout cas
quand on était coincé en France rien que
ça m'aime moins dépenses avoir dit le
retrouve mon moment rien que la même mot
qui a des danses derrière Elena la
montagne
[Musique]
et ben voilà on arrive sur le chemin
pavé en tout cas soleil il chauffe ou
plat à l'église alors je m'appelle il
faut savoir que l'île était pavé dans
les années 1750 ce chemin était si on va
dire grande fontaine colimaçon pour
rallier la ville de Saint-Leu et tombe
bien mais c'est là aussi ça va nous sur
la ville de Saint-Luc et ben je mets à
pavé allons-nous
mon pays comment il est la réunion
s'amène par le panneau allez nous verrez
la même un peu de respect pour mon pays
il avait vraiment après depuis son lit
au bout de la terre dans le paradis pour
comprendre faut un démon de mon pays ok
ben voilà après 34 minutes de marche
nous arrive lui a dit les batteries sans
culottes les batteries c'est deux canaux
là ici
en 1794 et le premier coup de canon à
donner c'était en faveur des Anglais en
1809 alors nous montre un GPS en haut
pour garder alors de la chinois voilà la
mer est magnifique
en tout cas les vrais
alors du coup ok
juste par là pour bien voir aller alors
belle roche là alors
dans la ville de Saint-Leu ben quand la
ville de moule
jusqu'à la ville en bas juste à côté
alors
au bout du sentier juste devant moi nana
la ville de Saint-Leu alors en parlant
de ville ici les réputés pour tortues et
tombe bien aujourd'hui on a une
opération aux abonnements à l'école et
ça prend de bois de faire en sorte comme
une tortue ça sent solo manae sur la
plage de Saint-Luc et ben nous ne savons
ça allez allons
-yves
comment il est ça va bien alors
pour être sur le terrain avec le CDTM
donc le CDTM c'est un nouveau partenaire
depuis la nuit dernière et nous commence
à les actions des plantations avec le
CDTM dans le cadre du plan en millions
d'arbres ah oui effectivement ok
d'accord c'est un programme ambitieux
que le département la met en place sur
l'ensemble du territoire et que les
décliné avec plusieurs partenaires des
collectivités publiques des entreprises
et des associations et donc on a des
plantations dans le cadre du Plan
million d'arbre dans le milieu naturel
dans les quartiers lequel dans le cadre
de l'opération bois de quartier et là
donc aujourd'hui nous les sur la plage
en bord de mer donc au niveau de
l'interface thermique et donc voilà nous
nous lance le partenariat avec le CDT
d'accord
et tout ça en fin de compte c'est pour
la tortue de mer parce que la tortue de
merde tu as fait beaucoup de pantalon
avant aujourd'hui il y a rien que deux
tortues qui viennent pour moi
en particulier
le sable donc il empêche la plage de de
partir en fait le sable de partir qui
maintient la plage il attire la tortue
parce qu'en fait c'est ces plantes là
qui étaient présentes pour la tortue il
est né et comment il revient parce
qu'ils font là où il est né d'accord
c'est en retrouvant l'odeur de ces pieds
de voilà c'est un bel événement mais
merci
balade est finie à la plage de Saint-Leu
l'autre chapelle redémarre viens du
clafontaine une patte chemin pavé et
nous on arrive sur la plage ok la radio
pour le temps Vitali et pour ça rendez
vous dans un prochain épisode de
l'émission Le nous sera du côté du trou
de fer regarde ce matin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]